[Music]
max is in chattanooga hey max how are
you
good for real better than we deserve
what's up
um so i just had a quick question um
right now i currently have a truck
payment that's about four hundred
dollars a month
and i have about six thousand eight
hundred left on it
and i have right now about sixteen
thousand dollars left
in my savings
and i just recently had to move out of
where i was living where i was able to
afford both the truck payment and my
rent and right now i'm living somewhere
where i don't know if i'll be able to
afford both of those and i was just
wondering if i should take the money out
of my savings and just go ahead and pay
the truck off well why'd you move
somewhere you can't afford
well it's not that i can't afford it it
was it's just that you can't afford it
well um i don't know if i can afford
both the truck payment and
the where i'm living currently um it was
kind of a very last minute thing and i
had to move in a couple of months
and um i just this was about the only
place that was available for me to move
into
how old are you
uh 22. okay i'm calling bs
you had a couple of months to make a
decision
and you made a decision to rent a place
you can't afford
that's you're not forced you were not
forced into this you are not a victim of
the real estate market in chattanooga
you're a victim of how lazy you were
when you were looking for a place to
live
yes
well we're on the same page we're on the
same page hey we love you man i love you
so how much you all on this truck you
said you owe 6 000 on the truck yes i'd
pay it off today what do you make of
your sir
um about 24 25 000. okay what do you do
um i work retail right now and i'm going
back to school next semester to finish
out my um degree and what
uh business management great good move
very good call
good so here's what we're gonna do i'm
gonna send you a copy of the book the
total money makeover to show you how to
handle money while you're fighting your
way through this i'm proud of you you're
doing good stuff here's the trick man
don't let stuff happen to you
on the money side you happen to it
you have to make things fit your world
you don't cave to the circumstances
around you or you will lose and that's
what puts you in this position
so i've done it too i know exactly how
it feels that's why i can pick on you